vous n'avez encore jamais tu es bon mais
pour devenir un double zéro il faut tuer
deux fois comment est il mort votre
contact douloureusement les y aucune
crainte
la deuxième fois et oui indéniablement
cet homme était le chiffre banquiers
privés des terroristes internationaux
ce qui expliquerait comment il a pu
organiser une partie de poker à haut
risque au casino royale au monténégro
s'il perd la partie le pourra fuir nulle
part vous êtes le meilleur joueur du
service et le trésor financera votre
mise durant la partie
et si vous perdez votre gouvernement a
directement financé le terrorisme
alors je compte bien garder l'oeil sur
l'argent de l'état
plutôt que sur votre exceptionnel petit
cul
vous avez remarqué notre parti ne vous
donne pas de sueur froide un j'espère ça
ne vous fait rien de tuer toutes ces
personnes je ne sois pas un très bon âge
en sus été le cas comment va la fille
at-elle fait fondre votre coeur de
pierre
j'ai mis ce fait là partir tu ne veux
pas t'ouvrir moi tu as remis de l'armure
je n'ai plus d'armé
tu me l'arraché
quoiqu'il reste deux mois
quoi que je sois je t'appartiens avec
une question sans réponse
pour retirer vous attend
le